Kim and Courtney and Chris sent me this
giant alpaca like it's not a real one
the Kardashians go big when it comes to
baby gifts literally
just look at the size of the famous
fam's present for Paris Hilton's Baby
Boy Phoenix it's a life-sized farm
animal but it's just so cool I have it
in the front of my house now it's the
cutest thing I like hug it every day who
wouldn't want to get cozy with this
cutie that's what's hot the over-the-top
offering is no surprise though Paris and
Kim have been besties since they were
kids we've known each other since we're
little girls I love her and I'm so proud
of her and her whole family they are
just girl bosses killing it Paris sort
of helped launch Kim's Billion Dollar
Empire as she was building her own see
Kim worked for Paris appearing on the
simple life just before striking gold
with her own reality TV career I really
would want to do anything for her she
literally gave me a career
and I like totally acknowledge that and
now Kim can repay the favor with all the
motherly advice she has to offer Kim's
of course got four kiddos with X Kanye
West I think after having kids it just
is such a life changer our life is so
different I feel like this is when life
really
begins and it's been so much fun to be
on this journey while Paris just
welcomed her first with husband Carter
Reem this year what did your mama Kathy
think you didn't tell her about the
birth of your son until a week after he
was born what was her reaction she was
very surprised and so just happy and
excited but for me I just was something
that I wanted to keep private when
you're a mom you're so excited to tell
everybody the news so
I knew I had to keep it a secret he's
only two months old that every day is
growing more and more so it's just good
just to soak in every moment
[Music]